What is Aptos?
What is Move?
What are you building?
My name is Chris Kim.
I'm a developer relations
engineer at Aptos Labs.
Recently been creating
a lot of AI tooling
for developers because
no one's manually coding anymore.
Now we're building agent skills
and all these cool
AI tooling for people.
What are you most
passionate and excited about?
Two main things that
we're focusing on for 2026
is Decimate Decibel
and Shelby.
Decentralized hot storage solution.
So it's really like
a good example for
the world to see that,
hey if you really
fully leverage the technology
that Aptos offers.
This is the type of
product that you can build.